Estoy seguro de que si os pidiera que localizarais
en un mapa o me dijerais algo característico
de países como Colombia, Venezuela, Argentina
o Brasil, la mayoría sabríais hacerlo.
Sin embargo, hay otros países de América
Latina que, sin saber bien por qué, suelen
pasar casi siempre completamente desapercibidos.
¿Y sabéis qué? Ese es precisamente el caso
de nuestro protagonista de hoy: Paraguay.
Piénsalo bien, ¿Qué sabes de Paraguay?
Seguro, seguro que muchos de vosotros no sabríais
contestarme a esta pregunta.
[Y sí, este es el primer vídeo específicamente
dedicado a Paraguay en toda la historia de
VisualPolitik. Ya tocaba]
El caso es que junto con su vecina Bolivia,
Paraguay es el otro país de América Latina
sin salida al mar, y además se encuentra
justo al lado de dos de las potencias regionales:
Brasil y Argentina.
Y, es cierto, Paraguay no es tan conocido
como sus dos potencias vecinas, pero esto
no quita para que tenga algunas características
que seguro, seguro nos llaman la atención
a todos.
Por ejemplo, que sea el primer productor de
marihuana de toda Suramérica es algo que
le pone inevitablemente en el radar internacional.
Y, no solo eso, desde Argentina muchas veces
se ha acusado a Paraguay de ser, incluso,
un paraíso fiscal por tener un impuesto de
sociedades y un IVA de solo el 10%.
Pero, seamos honestos, desde luego, si lo
comparamos con Argentina, cualquier lugar
va a parecer un paraíso fiscal.
Sea como sea, el caso es que Paraguay en 2022
estuvo en el candelero no por los impuestos
ni por la marihuana, sino por esta trágica
noticia:
N1(Asesinado en Colombia un fiscal antimafia
paraguayo durante su luna de miel. Euronews)
Efectivamente, queridos amigos, el año pasado
el fiscal Marcelo Pecci fue asesinado. Este
fiscal era una pieza clave del operativo contra
el narcotráfico conocido como “A Ultranza
Paraguay”.
Además, había estado colaborando con la
DEA y la Europol. Para que os hagáis una
idea, había conseguido identificar y detectar
a poderosos empresarios y políticos, tanto
de Paraguay como de algunos países de Europa,
involucrados en el tráfico de cocaína.
Por desgracia, apenas 3 meses después de
llevar a cabo más de 100 redadas simultáneas
y de incautar bienes valorados en más de
100 millones de dólares, en mayo de 2022
fue asesinado en frente de su mujer en la
ciudad de Cartagena, Colombia.
[Sí, estas cosas siguen pasando más allá
de Netflix]
Ahora bien, no penséis que fue un hecho aislado.
Lo cierto es que este caso está muy unido
a los proble más endémicos que sufre Paraguay.
Pensadlo bien, hablamos de uno de los mayores
productores de marihuana del mundo y ahora
también un punto principal en la distribución
de coca. ¿No pensáis que Pecci estaba incomodando
a algunas personas?
Pero ¡ojo!, porque en un país como Paraguay
no estamos hablando solo de narcos, sino de
algo mucho más profundo.
Queridos amigos, amigas, ¿A qué problemas
se enfrenta exactamente Paraguay? ¿Hasta
qué punto podemos considerarlos como algo
internacional? ¿Podrá el nuevo presidente
poner orden?.
En este vídeo te vamos a responder a estas
y otras preguntas. Pero antes, antes vamos
a ver un poco de historia.
T1(LA LARGA TRADICIÓN POLÍTICA)
Uno podría llegar a pensar que la historia
moderna de Paraguay es como la de cualquier
otro país de América Latina: es decir, desde
la independencia, una constante sucesión
de periodos democráticos y dictaduras de
todo tipo.
Y en parte así es, pero Paraguay tiene una
particularidad que prácticamente ninguno
de sus vecinos ha tenido [Salvo que consideremos,
claro está a México como un país vecino]
Me estoy refiriendo al total dominio político
de un único partido, la Asociación Nacional
Republicana, más conocido como el Partido
Colorado. Y, ojo, que hablamos de un dominio
inexpugnable.
(Fundado en 1870, el Partido Colorado no llegó
a gozar de un poder continuado hasta que gobernó
el país durante los 17 años que median entre
1887 y 1904. Sin embargo, su máximo esplendor
todavía tuvo que esperar algunos años.
Fue en 1954, con el comienzo del brutal régimen
del general Alfredo Stroessner - apoyado por
cierto por los Estados Unidos - cuando el
Partido Colorado comenzó su total hegemonía
política. Al fin y al cabo, Stroessner fue
el presidente de este partido durante toda
la dictadura.
Sin embargo, cuando en 1993 finalmente llegó
la democracia, a diferencia de lo ocurrido
en otros muchos países, el dominio de este
partido no sufrió demasiados contratiempos.)
Y de hecho, desde entonces, la presidencia
de los colorados solo se vio perturbada por
la presidencia de Fernando Lugo y muy temporalmente
por la de Federico Franco entre los años
2008 y 2013.
No obstante, la presidencia de Lugo quedó
embarrada por la masacre de Curuguaty, cuando
11 campesinos y 6 policías nacionales perdieron
la vida en un enfrentamiento para desalojar
unas tierras que llevaban más de un mes ocupados.
Aunque no está del todo claro lo que pasó
realmente porque muchas pruebas desaparecieron
y aparentemente la policía no siguió las
órdenes del ministerio del interior de incautar
solamente las armas a los campesinos.
Pero, sea como sea, la realidad es que esto
acabó con un juicio político que expulsó
a Lugo de la presidencia, lo que supuso un
duro golpe para los candidatos alternativos
al Partido Colorado… Que regresó al poder
para no volver a soltarlo.
En 2013 ganó Horacio Cartes, en 2018 Mario
Abdo Benítez y el último, a finales de abril
del 2023, Santiago Peña. Todos ellos candidatos,
por supuesto, del Partido Colo rado.
Santiago Peña, un economista de 44 años
que ha trabajado para el FMI y el Banco Central
de Paraguay, y que ya fue ministro de Hacienda
en el pasado, coge las riendas de un país
que desde comienzos de siglo ha registrado
un fuerte crecimiento económico, pero que
está duramente azotado por la pobreza, el
narco y otros problemas endémicos. Problemas
a los que ahora le tocará enfrentarse.
Ahora bien, ¿de qué estamos hablando exactamente?
Pues… Atentos.
T2(AL SERVICIO DE LAS COIMAS)
Seguro que muchos ya os habréis dado cuenta
de que la situación del Partido Colorado
se parece bastante a la que tuvo el PRI durante
esos largos 70 años que estuvo gobernando
México sin interrupción.
Y, claro, con tanto tiempo en el poder, sin
ninguna alternancia, creo que todos sabemos
cuál fue el resultado: una corrupción galopante
y el tráfico de influencias convertido en
toda una prioridad para los políticos. Pues
bien, el caso de Paraguay no ha sido diferente.
. Por eso, no puede extrañarnos que, a principios
de 2023 nos encontráramos con esta noticia:
N2 (EE.UU. sanciona al vicepresidente y al
expresidente de Paraguay por corrupción.
El expresidente y el actual vicepresidente
han estado implicados en un sistema de corrupción
que ha socavado las instituciones democráticas
de su país. El País)
Efectivamente, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
tanto al expresidente Horacio Cartes como
al actual vicepresidente, Hugo Velázquez,
han sido sancionados por el gobierno de Estados
Unidos por su corrupción continuada.
Por ejemplo, Cartes, que no deja de ser uno
de los empresarios más ricos del país, aparentemente
le pagó a los miembros de su partido 10.000
dólares por cabeza para que apoyaran su candidatura
a presidente. Y, n o solo eso, también se
ha visto envuelto en actividades de contrabando,
por ejemplo, pasando su propio tabaco a Argentina
y Brasil.
Y no solo eso, es que, además, tanto a Cartes
como a Velázquez se les ha acusado, incluso,
de aceptar sobornos del grupo islamista libanés
Hezbollah, que Estados Unidos considera un
grupo terrorista por sus vínculos con Irán.
Sin embargo, estos no son los únicos casos
de corrupción a gran escala que podemos encontrar
en el país.
Por ejemplo, durante las primeras etapas de
la Covid-19, el gobierno mandó a los ciudadanos
a comprar medicamentos que amortiguaran los
síntomas del Covid a las farmacias privadas.
¿Cuál fue el problema? Pues que, como ponía
en las cajas de los propios medicamentos,
estos estaban destinados a los hospitales
públicos. Y, ¿qué significa esto? Pues
básicamente que los medicamentos de los hospitales
fueron vendidos en el mercado negro… De
tal forma que o pagabas una barbaridad o te
quedabas sin ellos. Algo que, por cierto,
desencadenó protestas masivas.
No es para menos. Pensadlo bien, Paraguay
no tiene las mejores condiciones económicas
del mundo. Vale, sí, es cierto, su PIB per
cápita ha crecido mucho desde los 1.700 dólares
en el año 2000 a los 5.900 actualmente…
Lo que evidentemente lo miremos por dónde
lo miremos significa que seguimos hablando
de un país bastante pobre con carácter general.
Y de hecho, su Índice de Desarrollo Humano
es el más bajo de entre sus vecinos, a excepción
de Bolivia, y el número de pobres sigue siendo
muy elevado.
Pero aún más, ¿Y si os dijera que la corrupción
y el tráfico de influencias están hasta
cierto punto normalizados en la sociedad paraguaya?
Pues… Fijaos.
(En Paraguay, el aprovecharse de la posición
de un amigo, familiar o conocido para mejorar
la condición propia tiene incluso su propia
palabra: “orekueté”, que procede de la
lengua guaraní.
Desde luego suena mejor que tráfico de influencias.
Pero no solo la ética del “orekueté”
está aceptada. Es que la corrupción también
es parte fundamental del día a día de la
sociedad paraguaya. Es cierto, no es una corrupción
enorme que mueva millones a gran escala, pero
las “coimas”, los pequeños sobornos,
están a la orden del día, sobre todo si
hablamos de agilizar trámites administrativos.
)
Ya veis, la corrupción campa a sus anchas
en Paraguay, mientras el 25% de los 7 millones
de personas del país, es decir, unos 2 millones,
siguen viviendo en la pobreza. Y, para muchos
analistas, esta pobreza es la causa de otro
de los graves problemas del país. ¿Os imagináis
cuál puede ser? Veámoslo.
T3 (LA TRIPLE FRONTERA)
A lo largo de los años, os hemos contado
aquí en VisualPolitik muchos casos en los
que, debido a la pobreza, la gente se ha terminado
zambullendo en el mundo del crimen para mejorar
su posición: ya sea en México con los narcos
o en Nigeria con los grupos que roban petróleo,
entre otros ejemplos.
Pues bien, según muchos analistas, este es
también el caso de Paraguay.
Sin embargo, no todos están de acuerdo: para
algunos es la ausencia del Estado y la falta
de medios lo que ha hecho que en Paraguay
el crimen organizado se haya convertido en
una próspera industria.
Por ejemplo, el Ejército Popular Paraguayo,
que es una organización guerrillera que nació
en 2008 con una ideología marxista-leninista,
ha sido y sigue siendo ampliamente apoyado
por algunos campesinos que se sienten abandonados
por el Estado.
No obstante, aunque este grupo guerrillero
sea una preocupación constante para el gobierno,
no es, ni de lejos, el mayor de sus problemas.
Para eso tenemos que irnos hasta la llamada
Triple Frontera.
(En la Triple Frontera confluyen las fronteras
entre Paraguay, Brasil y Argentina, que están
divididas por el río Paraná. Pues bien,
este punto está considerado como uno de los
más calientes del mundo en términos de criminalidad.)
La debilidad o incluso ausencia de mecanismos
y funcionarios en la frontera capaz de agilizar
el comercio transfronterizo entre los 3 países
ha hecho que los grupos del crimen organizado
internacional encuentren en la Triple Frontera
un espacio relativamente cómodo donde poder
operar.
Hablamos de un espacio dónde se han llegado
a detectar operaciones de grupos criminales
como el taiwanés Bambú Unido, la mafia rusa
o, incluso, la yakuza japonesa.
Por supuesto, ninguno de ellos tiene tanta
presencia ni poder en la Triple Frontera y
Paraguay como el brasileño Primer Comando
de la Capital, el PCC. Es este grupo quien
controla las rutas del narcotráfico entre
Brasil, Bolivia y Paraguay.
Y, os estaréis preguntando, ¿cómo puede
darse semejante concentración de bandas y
grupos del crimen organizado? Pues por una
simple razón: la falta de medios de control.
De esta forma, mientras que el comercio legal
sufre todo tipo de restricciones, las barcas
y barcazas que usan los narcos para atravesar
el río Paraná y llegar al río Iguazú para
ir a Brasil, por ejemplo, lo hacen muchas
veces sin tener que parar para ser registrados
por falta de medios.
Y tres cuartas partes de lo mismo pasa con
los camiones de los comerciantes que cruzan
desde Paraguay a Brasil por el puente de la
amistad. En este caso, además, es habitual
que usen dobles fondos en los camiones que
transportan madera y soja.
Pero, no solo eso, incluso los aviones que
llegan cargados de cocaína desde Bolivia
a Paraguay y que aterrizan en pistas de vuelo
clandestinas no son detectados por la falta
de radares.
Sin embargo, a pesar de que la falta de medios
de control por parte del Estado sea más que
evidente, ese puede no ser el único problema.
Me explico, muchos analistas se preguntan
si estos grupos no están actuando con total
impunidad. Es decir, que detrás de todo volvería
a estar la generalizada corrupción del sector
público.
C1 (“La corrupción hace posible negociar,
de manera particular, el cumplimiento de la
norma con el fin de evadir su cumplimiento.
La consecuencia directa es la impunidad y
con ella se pretende evitar, por parte de
estas redes, una detención, un juicio o ir
a la cárcel (…)” – Sonia Alda Mejías,
doctora en Historia por la Universidad Autónoma
de Madrid e investigadora del Real Instituto
Elcano, 2020.)
No obstante, Paraguay no solo es una especie
de simbiosis entre el mundo criminal y la
corrupción. Paraguay también tiene una característica
que lo hace especialmente relevante en la
geopolítica mundial. Prestad mucha pero que
mucha atención.
T4 (UN CLUB CADA VEZ MÁS LIMITADO)
Si sois fieles seguidores de VisualPolitik,
seguro que sabéis que ya no quedan demasiados
países que reconozcan a la República de
China, es decir a Taiwán, como la auténtica
China.
Hablamos esencialmente de algunas pequeñas
islas-nación en Oceanía como Nauru o las
Islas Marshall, la Ciudad del Vaticano en
Europa o la antigua Suazilandia en África
que siguen manteniendo este reconocimiento…
Un reconocimiento que es, precisamente, en
Latinoamérica donde más peso tiene.
Es cierto, la mayoría son pequeñas islas
caribeñas como Santa Lucía, pero, por ejemplo,
Guatemala, Belice y Haití siguen reconociendo
a Taiwán como la auténtica China. ¿Y sabríais
decirme que otro país hace lo propio? 3,
2, 1… ¡Exacto! Hablamos de Paraguay. Y
de hecho, aunque no sea el más poblado de
todos ellos, sí es el más grande. Y, os
preguntaréis, ¿cómo es que Paraguay no
ha reconocido ya a la República Popular China
como han hecho la inmensa mayoría de sus
países vecinos? Pues, básicamente, podríamos
resumirlo en que Paraguay es un amigo muy
fiel.
Y es que, veréis, desde que la Paraguay del
General Stroessner reconociera a la Taiwán
de Chiang-Kai-shek por los valores anticomunistas
que ambos países compartían, Paraguay se
ha visto ampliamente beneficiado por su amistad
con el país asiático.
Ya sea con apoyo militar, entrenando a soldados,
mandando armamento, o con becas de estudios
universitarios a jóvenes paraguayos para
que estos puedan estudiar en Taiwán, el pequeño
país asiático ha hecho gala de su diplomacia
económica para mantener su relación con
el país más grande en reconocerlo.
De hecho, la sede del Congreso paraguayo,
inaugurada en 2003, fue construida en parte
con una ayuda de 20 millones de dólares que
Taiwán le dio. Además, el Partido Colorado
también pertenece a la Liga Mundial por la
Libertad y la Democracia, la antigua Liga
Anticomunista Mundial que se fundó en Taiwán
en 1966. Y, no solo eso, la cercanía de Paraguay
a Taiwán ha supuesto también que, sobre
todo desde la administración Trump, las relaciones
con Estados Unidos se han fortalecido.
No obstante, no penséis que esta amistad
agrada a todos. Hay muchos que ven en esta
relación una oportunidad perdida de ganar
más dinero si se reconociera a la República
Popular China. Y, bueno, algo de razón, quizás,
no les falta.
De hecho, son muchos los empresarios y políticos
paraguayos que consideran que si se reconociera
al régimen de Xi Jinping se podría lograr
que la balanza comercial del país fuera positiva.
Un ejemplo de este descontento es la Asociación
Paraguaya de Productores y Exportadores de
Carne, que se ha quejado numerosas veces de
las cuotas de importación a la carne que
impone Taiwán.
Un problema que el país de Chiang Kai-shek
solucionó en 2020 cuando eliminó esas cuotas
y permitió la entrada de carne paraguaya
prácticamente sin restricciones.
De esa manera, el gobierno paraguayo consiguió
que sus ganaderos no sintieran que se estaban
quedando atrás en comparación con Argentina,
Brasil o Uruguay, países que sí tienen un
enorme comercio con China.
No obstante, son estos tres países los que
quizás mayor frustración sienten con esta
decisión de Paraguay.
Veréis, Paraguay, junto con Argentina, Brasil
y Uruguay, forman el Mercado Común del Sur,
comúnmente llamado Mercosur.
Y, ¿qué es el Mercosur? Muy simple: es un
mercado común donde los productos y las personas
de los cuatro países se pueden mover más
o menos libremente entre ellos.
Y, no solo eso, además los tratados de libre
comercio con otros países que no forman parte
del Mercosur son negociados conjuntamente.
Y ¿Qué quiere decir esto? Pues que, si los
4 miembros no votan a favor de cerrar un acuerdo
comercial con un país concreto, simplemente
este no se puede llevar a cabo.
Seguro que ahora sabéis por dónde van las
quejas de los socios del Mercosur. Efectivamente,
queridos amigos, tanto Brasil, como Argentina
y Uruguay, quieren cerrar un acuerdo de libre
comercio con China. ¿Cuál es el problema?
Que Paraguay no vota a favor porque reconoce
a Taiwán y no a China, y si no vota a favor,
pues no se cierra el acuerdo.
Por eso, desde la presidencia de Fernando
Lugo en 2008, e incluso con la de Abdo Benítez,
se ha barajado la opción de cambiar de una
vez por todas a Taiwán por China, pero al
final ninguno se atrevió a dar el paso.
Y Santiago Peña ya ha dejado totalmente claro
que su socio preferente va a seguir siendo
Taiwán:
C2 (“Paraguay tiene una relación histórica
con Taiwán y esta relación no se puede cuantificar
simplemente en términos económicos. Hay
algo más que el comercio. El comercio es
importante, nosotros necesitamos generar progreso,
pero también tenemos que entender que las
relaciones tienen que basarse en valores democráticos”
– Santiago Peña, presidente electo de Paraguay,
2023.)
Ya los veis, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
los retos que le esperan a Santiago Peña
no son moco de pavo: aparte de la pobreza
en el país, el constante aumento del crimen
organizado y la corrupción endémica van
a ser asuntos prioritarios.
Sin embargo, al igual que muchos esperan no
ver cambios en cuanto a la posición de Paraguay
frente a Taiwán, también se duda mucho de
que Peña vaya a atacar la corrupción del
país.
Al fin y al cabo, el expresidente Horacio
Cartes, el mismo que ha sido sancionado por
Estados Unidos por su corrupción, es su mentor
político, y muchos ya se huelen que va a
protegerlo a toda costa.
Pero la pregunta ahora es para vosotros: ¿creéis
que Santiago Peña conseguirá hacer de Paraguay
un país más transparente? ¿Cuál creéis
que es la mejor manera de afrontar el crimen
organizado de la Triple Frontera? ¿Sucumbirá
finalmente Paraguay al atractivo mercado chino?
O, por el contrario, ¿seguirá siendo fiel
a uno de su vieja amiga Taiwán? Podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios. Como
siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
saludo y hasta pronto.